We’ve detected gravitational waves AGAIN!
And guess what caused the ripple in spacetime?
Yes!
MORE colliding black holes!
Hi there spacetime entities, Ian here for
DNews on a very, VERY big day for physics.
Since the discovery of gravitational waves
hit the headlines back in February, we’ve
been patiently waiting to see whether or not
it was a fluke.
And I can tell you now, it wasn’t!
The LIGO project has detected these ripples
in spacetime AGAIN.
It’s hard to put into words just how momentous
the first historic discovery of gravitational
waves is for science.
A little over 100 years ago Albert Einstein
predicted their existence, but it wasn’t
until the ultra-sensitive Laser Interferometer
Gravitational-wave Observatory, or Advanced
LIGO, went online that we stood a chance of
detecting them.
Gravitational waves are basically ripples
through spacetime, traveling at the speed
of light.
If you imagine ripples traveling across the
surface of a pond after dropping a pebble
into the water, you’d have a 2-dimensional
idea about what’s going on.
But to detect 3-dimensional gravitational
waves passing through Earth -- and therefore
passing through US -- we need a very, very
sensitive detector.
This is where LIGO comes in.
The project consists of two observing stations
-- basically two L-shaped buildings with two
and a half mile long tunnels -- one in Washington
and one in Louisiana, nearly 2 thousand miles
apart.
Two stations are needed to confirm the presence
of a gravitational wave signal and tell which
direction it’s traveling in.
And that’s what happened on December 26,
2015; a second spacetime “chirp” was detected.
Really, when converted into an audio representation,
gravitational waves sound like a “chirp,”
listen.
Through analysis, LIGO physicists were able
to deduce that the first LIGO chirp in September
was created by a black hole merger.
That first famous signal was generated by
two black holes, one 29 times the mass of
our sun and one 36 times the mass of the sun
getting trapped in a gravitational spiral,
eventually colliding and creating one large
black hole.
So that “chirp” is the cataclysmic collision
of two black holes some 1.3 billion light-years
away.
The most recent event, called GW151226, that
has just been announced TODAY was caused by
two smaller black holes, one 14 solar masses
and the other only 8 solar masses.
When they merged, they created one spinning
black hole of 21 solar masses.
Now, you may think my math is off, surely
14 plus 8 equals 22?
Where did that 1 solar mass go?
Well, during the collision, which happened
1.4 billion light-years away, one whole solar
mass of material was converted from matter
into energy and that energy is what created
the powerful gravitational waves that, literally,
shook spacetime.
Cool, right?
There’s more.
Because LIGO has 2 observing stations, we
can roughly work out where this black hole
merger occurred in the sky.
Check out this map of the general region of
sky where LIGO thinks these two black hole
mergers occurred.
In a statement, Caltech’s Albert Lazzarini,
the deputy director of the LIGO Laboratory
said: “LIGO is bringing us a new way to
observe some of the darkest yet most energetic
events in our universe”
And he’s not wrong.
We are seeing a revolution in astronomy -- for
the first time we can “hear” the passage
of gravitational waves from violent events
that occurred billions of years ago and deduce
what caused them.
Now there are plans for more gravitational
wave detectors to go online, including the
European Virgo project, so we can better understand
how many black holes there are in our universe
AND pinpoint WHERE these amazing black hole
mergers are happening.
The discovery of gravitational waves sent
ripples through spacetime and humanity, check
out Julia’s video about the first, historic
detection of gravitational waves.
Are you as excited as me about seeing black
holes collide?
Tell us in the comments section down below
and don’t forget click subscribe for new
episodes every day.
I’ll see you next time on DNews.